and here's the thing i think that
i think people get it more than they
ever have they understand you look at
some of these elite bureaucrats like
fauci you look at the corporate media
big tech the emperor has no clothes
these are
elites in our country and they don't
have your best interests at heart they
don't have this state's best interests
at heart
sometimes though it doesn't feel like
you know your voice can be heard because
so much of it is dominated by this one
viewpoint but when you stand up and you
stand in that fire and you fight back
for people man they will have your back
so i know we could do we could do
politics all day long and i do politics
for a living and these guys they're into
politics but there's something else
going on here i think that that you
exemplify which is just one man against
the system that you just said no and i
want to know just on a personal level
not at a political level where do you
think that came from within you was that
something that you always had i mean
when the covet stuff was happening and
everybody else locked down everybody
else followed falchi every you said no i
mean that's all you you just said no and
i wonder where did that really come from
within you
well look i think that there are people
that get involved in in elected office
who
uh are there to be able to enjoy the
accoutrements of office to be able to
have a title uh and then there are
people that get in because they actually
want to do something and they also want
to make a difference so i'm the latter
and
[Applause]
when i became
governor i remember going into the
office for the first time sitting in the
chair and i said um you know what uh i
don't know what sob is going to end up
succeeding me in eight years but i can
tell you this
there ain't gonna be any meat left on
the bone for them because i'm gonna take
on issues i'm gonna be on offense i'm
not just gonna sit back i'm gonna make
sure that we're really making a
difference but i would do it based on
what i thought was right
and i have not taken a poll since i've
been governor i'm not trying to react to
whatever some of you know random burst
of opinion
my view is is when you lead
if you set out the vision and you
execute the vision and you do well
people will follow that and that's what
they want to see and so
that was just my philosophy
and so when it came for like kovid you
know i remember like you know just
getting hammered by corporate press and
they politicized it they wanted to use
it to take out trump they wanted to use
it to take out people like me and that's
just what they do um but you know my
view was okay if by me protecting the
jobs of all the people i represent
ends up putting my own job in jeopardy
then so be it let the chips fall where
they may
i wasn't worried about politics
and i would totally be willing to um
because i look i have there's a great
there's a lot of opportunities in life
it didn't like i have to to do this and
so if it didn't work out for me i would
have been totally great being able to
look in the mirror and say you know what
i did what i thought was right to
benefit the people i represent i think
when you get in situations where some of
these politicians you know they get
paralyzed by polls and consultants and
everything and then they
don't do what they think and their guts
right because they're worried about
blowback they're worried about the media
they're worried about political
consequences well then guess what
happens you end up not succeeding most
of the time anyways then you end up
looking in the mirror like man i just
wish i would have followed what i
believed in and so you know no regrets
you got to do what you think is right
and in this case with florida
i
you know with kovid
i actually consumed the data myself i
didn't just i wasn't just you know
saying if fauci says something then you
got a genuflect what are they getting at
the data and the fact is fauci was wrong
about a lot of this stuff okay
we were the first big state to guarantee
every parent the ability to send their
kid to school in person way back in 2020
right
fauci opposed us having kids in school
he opposed what we were doing when we
had businesses open and protecting
people's jobs and were having these
events he opposed us every step of the
way and so that wasn't based on data
because the schooling was obvious that
you needed to have the kids in school it
was based more on ideology and it was
more based on all these other things so
we were right to have to stand up to
fouchy
we'll respect your free speech if you
respect ours but you gotta do it outside
you gotta do it outside so at the end of
the day that's just my philosophy and i
would just i think that you gotta do
what you think is right i i tend to you
know if there's a choice between going
against the machine and siding with the
folks i'm gonna side with the folks and
here's the thing i think that
i think people get it more than they
ever have they understand you look at
some of these elite bureaucrats like
fauci you look at the corporate media
big tech the emperor has no clothes
these are discredited elites in our
country and they don't have your best
interests at heart they don't have this
state's best interests at heart
sometimes though it doesn't feel like
you know your voice can be heard because
so much of it is dominated by this one
viewpoint but when you stand up and you
stand in that fire and you fight back
for people man they will have your back
they will support you and that's what
we've shown in the state of florida
see
he doesn't like poles but standing
ovations ain't bad you know
those are pretty good i got an idea so
you know if you weren't a politician
well how about this maybe and you guys
could chime in on this we don't have to
put the governor on the spot but maybe
like you know you crush it in this next
election here in florida let's do maybe
eight years in the white house and then
you become ceo of disney how does that
sound
[Music]
who knows what happens
you never know in life so
all right so so let's talk about some of
the other stuff that you're doing
because you really are doing stuff here
that is not happening in the rest of the
country you just signed uh this
fatherhood bill last month here this is
just another issue that you took on that
seemingly we need to talk about we don't
talk about honestly and you chose to to
fight it so tell me a little bit about
that
yeah i mean i think that if you look at
what's going on in our in our society
um
[Applause]
did they have to at least pay to get in
here okay good good good
i mean like look i get people have their
stick i get people you know do things a
little bit different on that side than
than we would but honestly it's so
ineffective no but all you do is tick
people off when you you try to interrupt
these events so keep doing it you're
just going to help us in the long run um
but
and you live in florida
florida
people but you know the fatherhood is is
interesting because if you look at
all the different problems society could
deal with a huge number of them are
rooted in kids growing up without having
a father in the home and
so i started getting involved in this
when i was my first year as governor
we're doing the budget there was some
money for a group called all pro dads
and it was founded by former bucks and
colts head coach tony dungy who's a
great guy and and tony
and you know look i just signed next
year's budget i vetoed a world ref
florida record 3.1 billion before i
became governor the record was like 800
million and so we're we're very tough
and i mean we will veto and so you can
veto individual items and so he called
me just to kind of like make the pitch
and you know i'm like honestly um i
trust you i know you're gonna your
heart's in the right place and i know
this is important so we started getting
involved we'd work with private groups
we'd work with our state agencies and
then this year kind of a more
comprehensive thing but if you talk to
coach dungey and he was at the bill
signing when he said when he became
tampa bay head coach he went to minister
at some of the prisons and he looked and
he said you know i noticed that it
wasn't
because of poverty race all these other
things the reason these people were in
prison was because they did not have a
father figure in the home and if you
could address that you would have so
much better luck in society overall so
that's what we're trying to do and part
of it is resources education part of it
though is sending a message to men
meet your responsibilities you have a
responsibility
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell